Caption: good afternoon everyone i hope you're
Caption: enjoying ddd perth's day my name is vidu
Caption: bhardwaj and i'm an i.t lecturer
Caption: and teaches future workforce so while
Caption: bringing me while being with my students
Caption: from different levels like search
Caption: research for diploma advanced diploma i
Caption: observed some factors which affect their
Caption: learning ability which affects their
Caption: ability to retain knowledge and some
Caption: factors which affect their behavior so
Caption: because same students are going to end
Caption: up as it professionals so i believe same
Caption: factors would work there so today i'm
Caption: going to share that
Caption: such factors and strategy which can help
Caption: to embed cyber security into business
Caption: culture
Caption: before we start i would like to
Caption: acknowledge the traditional custodians
Caption: of this land logic people of the ningar
Caption: nation
Caption: and a big thanks to all our amazing
Caption: sponsors
Caption: so
Caption: for embedding cyber security into your
Caption: business culture i will be focusing on
Caption: these three areas why what and how
Caption: but major
Caption: uh discussion will be around how but how
Caption: we can do that
Caption: but we still need to go through why in
Caption: what
Caption: so i believe you all know that
Caption: why cyber security is so important
Caption: but why is it so important to embed that
Caption: into business culture
Caption: so
Caption: there's lots of research going around
Caption: this area and i have some stats to share
Caption: with you
Caption: 90
Caption: of cyber security incidents
Caption: are human-enabled so that's a big number
Caption: which cannot be ignored and should not
Caption: be avoided
Caption: also according to another report the
Caption: most common methods of deploying
Caption: ransomware are
Caption: poor user practices 25
Caption: weak passwords 30 percent
Caption: lack of cyber security training 36
Caption: and spam phishing email 67
Caption: so these are the top four methods they
Caption: were more but i just took the top four
Caption: methods which
Caption: people used to
Caption: uh
Caption: used for a ransom attack now what is a
Caption: common thing among these four
Caption: points these four
Caption: methods can you can anyone guess what's
Caption: the common
Caption: thing in these among these four
Caption: absolutely yes so
Caption: human beings so we as human are
Caption: unpredictable
Caption: like whether we can
Caption: guess but we cannot be hundred percent
Caption: sure
Caption: and yes we are sensitive to
Caption: emotions play a big role when it comes
Caption: to social engineering so we tend to get
Caption: trapped with emotions so that's why
Caption: that's the reason that many phishing
Caption: emails are successful
Caption: many uh social engineering acts are
Caption: successful so this is the big area we
Caption: cannot ignore this factor of cyber
Caption: security
Caption: now
Caption: how companies are controlling this
Caption: scenario what they are using what helps
Caption: them to establish a security-minded
Caption: business culture
Caption: well many companies have some sort of
Caption: program in place which they use to
Caption: make their employees or team members
Caption: aware of cyber security
Caption: but in academic language we can
Caption: uh say it's called sata or cyber set up
Caption: cyber security education training and
Caption: awareness now i'm not going into detail
Caption: of this
Caption: program but
Caption: i would like to ask you certain
Caption: questions
Caption: so that you can analyze whatever program
Caption: or training model you have in place
Caption: you can create critically analyze it so
Caption: think about it is it just a checklist
Caption: do you just do it for the sake of doing
Caption: it
Caption: is it engaging enough
Caption: how often do you do that
Caption: and are you sure it is working
Caption: so think about it
Caption: but we will i will share what you can do
Caption: to make it better
Caption: so how to embed cyber security into your
Caption: business culture how to do it that's
Caption: what we're going to discuss today
Caption: but before that how not to do it
Caption: so
Caption: these are some headlines from recent
Caption: news a railway company
Caption: sent fake bonus email to your employees
Caption: to check their cyber awareness
Caption: another company godaddy
Caption: announced a surprise holiday bonus
Caption: and there was one more company which
Caption: promised even covid vaccines can you
Caption: believe this is big no no
Caption: they may with such acts they may get to
Caption: test their cyber awareness of the
Caption: employees but they're definitely going
Caption: to
Caption: destroy the trust
Caption: which we cannot afford because as we
Caption: know humans are or our employees are the
Caption: front line when it comes to cyber
Caption: security so
Caption: have to be mindful with such acts
Caption: so useful tactics so these are going to
Caption: be the main takeaways from my today's
Caption: presentation
Caption: training
Caption: that's the
Caption: that's the main module which we deliver
Caption: in our organizations so
Caption: very important that it should be
Caption: customized so if you are getting it from
Caption: somewhere you're buying it from
Caption: somewhere or you are asking someone to
Caption: build it for your company make sure it
Caption: is according to your business needs it
Caption: should be customized as per the nature
Caption: of your
Caption: organizational
Caption: structure
Caption: and has to be in small chunks so it's
Caption: human tendency that they cannot retain
Caption: knowledge if it is
Caption: overloaded so again this i have observed
Caption: from my own experience
Caption: if we give some information in small
Caption: chunks the ability to retain that
Caption: knowledge gets higher and they get some
Caption: time to digest the information in
Caption: between
Caption: handouts help as well
Caption: next it has to be inclusive so there
Caption: might be people who are non i who are
Caption: from non-iit background people may be at
Caption: reception or someone who's just taking
Caption: care of asset so make sure you have you
Caption: train them as well you make them as part
Caption: of your cyber security training or cyber
Caption: awareness training right so don't
Caption: exclude anyone
Caption: simple reporting system
Caption: very important
Caption: so make sure your employees or team
Caption: members know how to report any potential
Caption: incident any potential cyber security
Caption: incident or
Caption: if they if any cyber attack happens or
Caption: anything like that they should know how
Caption: to report
Caption: whom to report
Caption: and such system should be simple and
Caption: quick
Caption: really going to impact law
Caption: now once you have trained it's very
Caption: important that you remind them about it
Caption: regularly so regular reminders should be
Caption: there it can be using um
Caption: tools like
Caption: uh cross departmental talks or having it
Caption: as standing agenda standing item on
Caption: meeting agendas like we have whs as
Caption: standing item on our general meetings
Caption: the same way we can discuss this in
Caption: every meeting so that everyone
Caption: stay away and stay alert
Caption: another tool you can use is
Caption: e-newsletters really handy because
Caption: every day something new happens in cyber
Caption: security world so you should
Caption: share this with your employees with your
Caption: team members
Caption: again cross department
Caption: talks should be there on such
Caption: incidents so easy to e-newsletters are
Caption: very handy and they are always there in
Caption: your phone in an email
Caption: and
Caption: last but not the least set an example so
Caption: if you yourself are
Caption: always talking about it always staying
Caption: aware of it and uh
Caption: people will
Caption: will see that how you are treating cyber
Caption: cyber security and they will get
Caption: inspired from you so that
Caption: really makes a difference
Caption: now very important that after you have
Caption: conducted all these things you have put
Caption: so much effort it's really important
Caption: that you get to know whether it's
Caption: working or not so you can do testing but
Caption: you have to be very careful you know why
Caption: like we just discussed so tools can be
Caption: used like service before and after
Caption: training
Caption: and regular audits these can be in the
Caption: form of phishing email attacks but do
Caption: not promise anything
Caption: gamification
Caption: so uh you can
Caption: entertain and get entertained and get
Caption: tested uh
Caption: using the game so i believe
Caption: it won't be a big task for
Caption: game developers or software developers
Caption: so this is kind of
Caption: uh different ways through which you can
Caption: check your
Caption: cyber awareness program
Caption: now there is a difference between
Caption: cyber aware and cyber culture
Caption: so because we want that uh to be
Caption: embedded into cyber culture it is very
Caption: important that it comes from within so
Caption: all these points if they are there
Caption: they're definitely going to stay alert
Caption: and they will always
Caption: talk about it and it will be there in
Caption: their mind and they will be very
Caption: cautious before clicking any
Caption: link or any suspicious activity
Caption: last but not least acknowledgement again
Caption: from my own experience i observe that
Caption: people tend to perform better when they
Caption: are acknowledged when they are
Caption: recognized so after doing the test you
Caption: need to give them constructive feedback
Caption: so that they get to know how they are
Caption: going and what area they need to improve
Caption: on and
Caption: you can
Caption: discuss all the points with them it
Caption: builds trust as well
Caption: you can also give some rewards
Caption: on identifying any potential threat so
Caption: rewards can be in any form like a coffee
Caption: mug or a t-shirt which says
Caption: um
Caption: cyber aware
Caption: employee of the month or something like
Caption: that so you can be innovative here
Caption: now all these points looks very simple
Caption: but they are very impactful so i really
Caption: want that you should
Caption: implement these points in your existing
Caption: cyber awareness program if you have any
Caption: or you are
Caption: trying to get a new program or
Caption: such system in place
Caption: so
Caption: in summary i would say that to embed
Caption: cyber security business culture you need
Caption: to have a customized program which is
Caption: inclusive engaging and should not
Caption: destroy trust so
Caption: keep all these things in mind now um
Caption: i have written this in detail as well
Caption: all these points and some resources that
Caption: are
Caption: you can read on this link
Caption: and
Caption: you can also reach me through linkedin
Caption: which i have given there
Caption: thank you for listening